Christina Aguilera plays coy about her  rumored performance with a hologram of  Whitney Houston on the voice I'm very  excited about the finale after lots of  speculation a source confirmed to ET on  Monday that a hologram of the late  Whitney Houston will appear on stage  with Christina Aguilera this season on  The Voice the coach opened up to et on  Monday  aren't to secrecy I can't say anything  but I'm very excited about the finale  NBC declined to comment but we know one  thing's for sure  Houston's hologram is set to hit the  road last year hologram USA and  Houston's sister-in-law Pat Houston  announced plans for a world tour where  the singers hologram will headline shows  and play her biggest hits